[UPBEAT MUSIC]
We're just living
in a time where
AI is transforming everything.
It's transforming how we
work within disciplines,
like science, or climate
change, or medicine,
or all forms of technology.
It's driving
economies worldwide.
And in some cases, it's
leading to outcomes
that perhaps weren't
as intended, and not as
equitable and beneficial as
we would hope them to be.
And this really powerful
disruptive technology,
there's a lot of
good an opportunity.
But there's potential
for downside
that we have to just
be really mindful of.
People are interacting
with and using AI every day
and they don't even know it.
Like, YouTube is feeding
them up a next video.
Why that video?
In my research, I know, because
I developed these systems.
I developed these systems to
help people learn new things.
I build systems that
help persuade people
to take healthier actions.
These are technologies
that are influencing
the way we learn, our decisions,
our opinions, our behaviors.
It is a technology
that people use.
It's our decisions is what's
causing it to be applied
in the way that it is, right?
So having people
just understand what
AI is, that it is a
tool for empowerment.
It also has the risk of
exacerbating inequality
if we're not careful, right?
So it's a change agent,
in a way, that people just
need to be much more
savvy and cognizant about,
so they can make intelligent
informed decisions.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
We created Raise, which is a
new MIT-wide initiative, that
stands for Responsible
AI for Social Empowerment
and Education.
We're creating these
innovative curriculum that
introduce-- not only AI
concepts and technologies,
but responsible
design practices,
as well as societal implications
of these technologies, where
the students are placed as
the designer of these systems
in our approach.
And we educate them
in these methods.
They build things with it.
They design things in groups.
How do you make learning
experiences more high touch,
more engaging, more
emotionally engaging?
So being able to track the
learners emotional state,
their attentional state.
Adapting the experience and
the content accordingly.
Innovations around VR,
AR, immersive space,
it's just other
ways of inventing
how we can bring much more of
a face-to-face, interpersonal,
emotionally engaging experience
to learning at distance
through digital technologies.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]